[Music]
godzilla vs kong brings the smackdown
but
sidesteps some of the smaller details on
the road to two giant monsters duking it
out
from missing titans to character deaths
here are our top questions
godzilla king of the monsters concluded
with a provocative image
all of us titans bowing before godzilla
officially crowning him a monster
royalty
the movie's end credit sequence pushed
things even further as godzilla kept
them all in line
the titans become forces for good
creating new rainforests in desolate
lands
healing decimated animal populations
even stopping the effects of global
warming
this sequence seems like it's setting
the stage for godzilla vs kong's big
showdown too
as news reports reveal seismic
disturbances on skull island are
attracting the titans attention
but then nothing not only do we never
learn what happened when the titans
reach skull island but those characters
are missing from godzilla vs kong
entirely
a throwaway line explains that the
titans haven't been seen for three years
but that doesn't explain why they
disappeared godzilla vs kong's opening
credits
lists a number of titans that have been
defeated by godzilla but that doesn't
mean they're dead but you already know
that godzilla needs to keep the other
titans in line every now and then
narratively it's probably best that
godzilla vs kong focuses on the two
biggest straws but it's still odd that
the rest of the titans are completely
missing
during the kaiju grudge match of the
century
at the end of godzilla king of the
monsters eco-terrorist alan jonah
was down but not out sure his attempts
to save the earth by unleashing the
titans
and causing an extinction level event to
wipe out all humans failed but he seemed
to have other tricks up his sleeve as
king of the monster's post-credits
sequence revealed
jonah bought one of monster zero's
severed heads by all indications he
planned to use it for nefarious purposes
what those purposes are remains to be
seen while ghidorah's corpse is a key
plot point in godzilla vs kong
it's not clear if this is the same body
part that jonah secured in the previous
movie
even if it is that raises more questions
and answers mechagodzilla actually
relies on two monster zero skeletons
one skull is used in the pilot's
interface while another is in the
robotic kaiju itself
so even if this skull was originally
jonas apex still had to find another one
and if that is the case how did apex get
the skull from jonah if it's not
then where is jonah and just rogue kaiju
head either way what was he originally
planning
yes might have gotten away with it too
it wasn't for these blasted kids and
their dogs
so it's that just replace dog with
godzilla
see how it all leads back to scooby-doo
everything does
tragic pasts and dead families drive a
lot of the action in godzilla vs kong
madison lost both her brother and her
mother in titan attacks
nathan linde is haunted by the death of
his brother who perished trying to enter
hollywooth
little jia's entire family died when
storms ravaged skull island wiping out
their e-way
even kong himself as an orphan kong
skull island revealed that the skull
crawlers killed his parents which is one
big reason why he relates so much to jia
conspiracy theorists and undercover apex
employee bernie hayes has some tragedy
in his past too
as he explains to madison and her friend
josh he wasn't always alone
at one point he had a loving wife who
gave him a flask of whiskey that he
keeps in a gun holster
when josh needs to disrupt the satellite
signal that gives mecha godzilla its
power that flask comes in handy
but without more information it feels a
little bit like a deus ex machina not
only do we never learn why bernie's wife
gave him such an odd gift but we never
know exactly what happened to her
presumably her death has something to do
with bernie's transformation from family
man to conspiracy loving nutcase
but in the absence of any real
information we'll just have to use our
imaginations
the ewe skull islands indigenous people
play a big role in kong skull island the
movie that introduced kong to the
monster verse the movie shows how the
ewe rescued and befriended hank marlow
as well as the members of the monarch
expedition they worshipped kong like a
god
and relied on him to protect them from
the giant monsters that plagued the
island
the ewes won't speak their name but i
call them skull crawlers
why because it sounds neat however by
the time that godzilla vs kong rolls
around
they're gone as the movie explains a
storm ravaged skull island and wiped out
all of the e-way
save for a little girl named jia
unfortunately that's all we get
it's an explanation that strikingly odd
in its brevity
after all storms have hit skull island
plenty of times before
the entire island is perpetually
surrounded by one which is why it
remains secluded for so long
given godzilla vs kong's fascination
with weird pseudo-science
there's clearly more going on here maybe
the storm has something to do with the
mysterious seismic activity
and increasing geological instability on
the island hinted at in godzilla king of
the monster's credit sequence
maybe it's a side effect of hollow earth
or the big increase in titan activity
maybe the storms created by ghidorah and
king of the monsters did the job
we will probably never know for sure
though and that's a shame
mothra met a tragic ending godzilla king
of the monsters when king ghidorah
vaporized her with one of his gravity
beams
marthra's ashes seemed to give godzilla
the power up he needed
to take ghidorah down but the end
credits hinted that she may not be gone
for good
monik finds massive egg could giant
insect dead be a second mothra or
something else
a headline of the united world news
website proclaimed according to the news
story the egg was discovered inside
mothra's territory and was taken to a
monarch research lab for further study
by the time that godzilla vs kong rolls
around it hasn't been forgotten either
one episode of bernie's podcast titan
truth carries the title
mothra pregnancy theory and has the
following subhead
so who's the baby daddy these are all
good questions but godzilla vs kung
doesn't provide the answers in the
original japanese godzilla films mothra
is a mystical being who often goes
through a cycle of death and rebirth
similarly king of the monsters implies
there have been other mothras before
if the monster verse continues martha's
return seems almost inevitable
we just don't know how quite yet apex
cybernetics doesn't send
kong nathan dr eileen andrews and gia to
hollyworth out of the goodness of its
corporate heart it wants something
specifically apex ceo walter simmons is
after hollywood's ultra powerful energy
source which he hopes to use to make
mecha godzilla the ultimate anti-titan
weapon he succeeds too
once the hollyworth expedition
identifies the energy source
simmons daughter maya takes the sample
analyzes it
and sends her findings to dia old dad
she tries to escape through the new
godzilla maid tunnel to the surface with
a sample too
but kong's too quick for her the giant
ape grabs the heave that maya is fleeing
in and with one flex of his hand
crushes it into bits it doesn't matter
apex receives maya's transmission and
within minutes
supercharges mechagodzilla but hold on
that's not really how power typically
works
usually you need an actual substance in
hand to extract energy or to create a
chemical reaction or something
power isn't really something that can be
delivered via email
not scientifically possible it's
possible that apex was able to quickly
replicate the hollyworth energy source
using maya's data and pump it into
mechagodzilla immediately but the whole
thing happens so fast that it's
extremely unclear
as a sequel godzilla vs kong pulls
double duty
it's a follow-up to both godzilla king
of the monsters and kong skull island
a few king of the monsters characters
resurface in godzilla vs kong
and the film references a few more when
serizawa apex's chief technical officer
and mechagodzilla's pilot is the son of
ishiro sarazawa who was introduced in
godzilla and heroically sacrificed
himself to save godzilla in king of the
monsters
unfortunately kong skull island's main
characters don't get the same treatment
while world war ii vet hank marlow was
likely passed on
james comrade would be in his late 80s
while war photographer mason weaver
should only be in her 70s comrade
actually appeared briefly in the king of
monsters prequel comic
godzilla aftershock which is set just a
few months after the 2014 godzilla movie
as an elder monarch agent
weaver however hasn't been seen since
the end of skull island
given that godzilla vs kong is the first
movie to continue skull island storyline
you'd expect kung's closest human allies
to at least cameo
if they're still alive and kicking
godzilla vs kong offers viewers a few
reasons why the two monsters don't like
each other
first they're both alpha titans meaning
the earth quite literally isn't big
enough for the both of them
then there's the fact that godzilla
constantly endangers people kong cares
about the biggest and most compelling
explanation however
is that there's bad blood between their
two families as documented in legends
and ancient
art godzilla and kong's ancestors were
the hatfields and mccoys of monsters
spending generations caught up in a long
and brutal war
that sounds awesome but godzilla vs kong
only offers hints as to how this
conflict unfolded
a stray line of dialogue here a
mysterious cave drawing there
finally when kong returns to his
ancestral home in hollow earth it seems
like the movie is going to deliver the
goods
but what we do get that awesome godzilla
spike axe is just another tease it sure
looks like the kong family emerged
triumphant in his epic struggle
after all you don't sit on a throne
unless you've earned the title of king
but there's a good chance you won't ever
know exactly what happened
for the most part the human characters
in godzilla vs kong are nearly as
interesting as the monsters
but villain walter simmons does get one
standout moment
near the movie's climax when simmons has
maddie josh
and bernie dead to rights he launches
into a good old-fashioned supervillain
monologue where he recounts a dream he
had
after godzilla first appeared
unfortunately he never gets to finish as
he's killed by mecca godzilla
mid-monologue
bachelor oozes slimy charisma but
simmons motivation in godzilla vs kong
feels just a wee bit undercooked
knowing what motivated simmons would
have made him a lot more interesting
and it's too bad he didn't get another
minute or so to fully explain what he
had up his soon to be devoured sleeve
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie moments are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you